foreign
what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation Greg here today as all you
guys are aware there's been a writer
strike going on and as of last week the
SAG strike is now happening there's some
great videos that you guys can watch
about it I mean I myself just did a
podcast with Paul heavy spoilers or
podcasts Across the Universe where we
gave our very much impassioned
discussion about the sex strike we are
of course in support of the SAT strike
if you want to watch it's like a great
like breakdown of it the best one that
I've seen I would have to say is Dan
Merle's video of really breaking down uh
exactly what the SAG strike is
completely all about it's really well
informed it's an entertaining one as
well what I wanted to focus on today
specifically is what influencers can and
cannot do in regards to the sex strike
of what would be deemed okay and
acceptable and what would ultimately be
a violation going against the SAG strike
order when you go online you're going to
see like a whole bunch of discourse
about what is okay and what is not okay
are people allowed to review Barbie and
Oppenheimer can they do this can they do
that like what's all right what isn't
all right and so what I've done uh you
know I spent a long time on this I have
cross-referenced with the Stag strike
order that was sent out the FAQ about
influencers that was sent out and then a
little bit ago variety they just
published an article where they've laid
out even more rules I made it even
clearer of what you can and cannot do
and I also did speak with a publicist
isn't really concerned about their
clients they wanted to understand a lot
of the rules and on top of that too I
have been talking with people who are
members of Sac who are also on press
there's just a lot of different notes
and all compiliters so this is the best
that I could do I just wanted to give a
really straight forward kind of
reference breakdown sheet for you all of
everything I was able to gather between
three categories here the first category
I'm going to talk about if you are a
union influencer if you are sag and you
are also an influencer and also if
you're a non-union influencer and the
third thing I want to talk about is with
all this information of how the real
rejects wishes to proceed moving forward
so with that in mind if you guys can
leave a like on this video that'd be
very much appreciated I'm going to be
incredibly direct with you all I know
normally I go off the dome but I just
kind of made a bunch of notes and I just
wanted to make something that could be a
solid reference for everyone because yes
this would be good if you are an
influencer and you are concerned about
this secondly there's a lot of viewers
out there who want to make sure that
their influencers are you know following
the guidelines here and I know some
won't care at all but for those who do
care this is for you lastly at the same
time if I happen to get anything
blatantly wrong please do the YouTube
thing be comment police because some
stuff is not entirely clear and that's
why variety even had to put out that
article where sag had to elaborate even
more and there's some stuff that does
require further elaboration but based
off my research this is the best I could
find but like I said there's anything I
get like definite like definitive like
no that's completely wrong I want you to
correct me and I want that comment to be
highlighted that way people will see the
right thing alrighty so let's get to it
if you are an influencer here's what you
can do you can do commercial works this
is brand deals that align with sag after
rules so essentially you can work with
Brands you usually collaborate with as
long as you follow the Union's rules
however if a brand deal involves a
company currently on strike contact
influencer at sagafter.org to make sure
you're on the right track okay and
here's an important one as well because
if you happen to see an influencer
promoting a product that you know is
from one of these struck companies one
thing you want to make sure of if it's
something that is a concern of you is
did they get this deal before the strike
officially happened because they can
carry out existing contracts with struck
companies but they can't take on new
ones so basically if you've agreed to
promote a struck company before the
strike began stick to your word but
don't start new projects with these
companies during the strike actually
we're in in that boat right now I just
remembered is that we have a uh three
brand deals I want to say that uh we
have already submitted for that we've
already got the you know the edit done
for them now it's just been like okay
we're waiting for you to go yep post it
that was a couple weeks ago and as many
YouTubers will tell you some brands are
they take like six weeks to finally be
like all right but we're already in
contract with them but during the strike
we've already told our brand manager
that for the remainder of the strike
while it's happening to not accept
anything that comes in from a studio so
you want to hold me accountable I I
believe it's three that we've got you
can keep creating and posting content as
long as it's not about the work on
strike continue sharing your usual
content just avoid discussing the
companies or work on strike all right so
here's what you can't do take on new
jobs to promote struck companies simply
put avoid starting new collaborations
that involve promoting content from
companies currently on strike what
you'll discover here is most of this is
going to boil down to just don't promote
for them I know that part gets a
little bit like wait but what is does
that mean promoted it'll go into more
details you can't post about any work on
strike whether you're paid or not this
means avoiding the promotion of struck
company's content on your social
platforms cannot participate in events
like Comic-Con to promote struck
companies or work you can go to these
events but don't engage in promoting The
Struck work there real rejects we do
have a Comic-Con panel coming up that we
did agree to uh a long time ago we got
to do that but it's not for like a
studio or anything of that sort either
way well it should just be business as
usual this part's the one that I see a
lot of debate over you cannot take part
in activities like cosplay of characters
from struck work basically avoid
promoting struck companies through your
character portrayal so yeah that kind of
takes takes a lot of Cosplay out the
window at that point from the sound of
it it sounds like if you are sagged they
really want you to not be doing cosplay
if you're non-union that they're more
like sure go ahead
um but yeah either way I mean I still
think it's a an interesting one to lay
down so then the big question that was
asked here on the FAQ page was how does
this apply to me if I'm a non-union
influencer any non-member seeking future
membership in Sag after who performs
covered work or services for a struck
company during the strike will not be
emitted into membership in Sag after all
right so what does this mean exactly
first off really if you're not
interested in any of the SAG after
business and you are an influencer you
can really do whatever you want it's
your choice so I'm speaking of those who
are not Union who still care to not
break violation still want to make sure
that they can one day be eligible to be
sagged and if you're not an influencer
I'm also speaking to those who care to
see if the influencers they follow are
following the rules laid out a lot of it
comes down to is if you want to make
sure you can still be part of sag in the
future but the thing that they specify
that you cannot do is do covered work
for a struck company if you're planning
to join sag after essentially if you
hope to join the union one day avoid
working with struck companies so what
does cover work entail what does that
actually mean especially based off of
their guidelines without me just giving
you essentially a whole bunch of
exposition here mainly what it comes
down to is avoid any and all promotional
work when it comes to working with
Studios which usually involves a
financial transaction of some sort an
official agreement whether that be hey
you know come attend this influencer
event where we're going to give you free
food and drinks and all you got to do is
post about our movie just some kind of
mutual understanding that you are
actively working to help promote the
movie and yes of course like don't don't
act in anything you know like you know
the obvious stuff of not to do like
don't don't do any of that stuff like
auditions for struck projects and all
that so yeah don't do any of that but in
terms of the promotional work that's
that's the main thing you got to be
concerned about because here's where
people were often getting confused on
but do reviews quantify as that I'll go
into that in just a tiny bit so
essentially cover worked what it could
be promoting a struck company's content
attending events to promote a truck
company like a movie premiere
participating in a campaign that
indirectly promotes a struck company and
while they made it crystal clear on some
things here there is one statement that
they did put out that I'm glad they did
because some stuff does perhaps require
some more clarification because when
asked what happens if I break the strike
rules the answer was if you do it
inadvertently someone will probably tap
you on the shoulder and remind you not
to do it again but the union absolutely
has the power to enforce its strike
rules penalties may include censor
reprimand fine suspension and or
expulsion if you are not a member and
perform struck work you will be barred
from joining the Union in the future
well that ends on a really like dark
note originally it was sounded like if
you do anything wrongly wrong you're
going to be barred permanently Fine
Lines a lot of us influencers everyone a
lot of people are just trying their best
right now a lot of people who really do
care about her are trying their best and
at the end of the day if you do believe
you're doing you know what is within
your writing is not a violation of the
strike rules I don't think you have to
worry about you know being banished to
hell right away okay now let's talk
about uh real rejects because our
Channel essentially does like the main
variety of what other channels also also
do even if it's not like specifically
like hey an Easter egg breakdown or
whatever it's still essentially in in
the similar categories it's all right
like a lot of people know I'm not the
biggest fan of the word influence I have
nothing against influencers whatsoever
I'm one of them but I just don't really
like that word too much but at the end
of the day I am that and that's my
category now our other category is
entertainment journalist that's why
we've been on pressless for so many
years that's what we are qualified as on
the on the Press list sometimes there's
like an influencer press list and then
there's a entertainment journalist press
listen and we're always on the
entertainment journalist press list
because at the end of the day all of our
content is created for purposes of
commentary analysis and or review so if
you're one of those channels as well
where your content is created for those
purposes then I feel like this will all
be applicable for you so and look at the
categories here let's talk about movie
reviews so reviews they serve as a
journalistic role the whole point is to
provide impartial critique rather than
promotion like the whole point is to
offer analysis to help viewers you know
choose what to watch or encourage or
discourage urge you know however it may
be what's really essential though is
that reviewers don't accept payment for
positive reviews I mean I don't feel
like you should ever do that just in
general especially now don't expect
payment for positive reviews from struck
companies as this would completely enter
that promotional territory and the
Variety article they cleared this up
like Crystal when asked I'm a film
critic can I review movies the answer
was absolutely critics are not on strike
and are not obligated to stop reviewing
movies or TV shows that clears that up
follow it up with I'm an entertainment
journalist can I cover movies and TV yes
entertainment journalists whether they
belong to a union or not are not on
strike even those broadcast journalists
who are represented by sag-aftra are not
affected as the strike relates only to
the TV theatrical contract so there you
have it reviews are okay there was a
question in there that was starting to
confuse some people that was about
influencers can influencers promote a
movie again that question was about can
influencers promote category of covered
Services recovered work which obviously
that right there that's the big No-No
when researching into movie news
reporting movie news should be
acceptable because the whole point is it
aims to inform the public right not to
promote struck companies so again
impartial news coverage that does in
favor struck companies doesn't violate
strike rules all right trailer reactions
and reviews these are usually seen as
commentary or critique that generally
falls under fair use laws despite
whatever them music companies are always
fighting with on those trailers you're
always doing like the whole point is to
help encourage or help viewers to
understand what to expect from a film or
a show and they don't inherently promote
struck companies so that should be okay
movie and TV show reactions so if you're
doing episode reactions or a movie
reaction of course this is all like
really much you know edited cut up that
always leads into a full-on review the
main purpose of a reaction video is for
entertainment commentary to uh spur a
conversation about the content and of
course the movie and TV show are always
to support the other half of the video
review to the analysis section as long
as these reactions aren't endorsing or
promoting a struck company they're
generally acceptable and then from
everything I can see and read up on as
what's been laid out here in the Variety
article and knowing that there are a sag
members in the Press who have been going
to press screenings you're an
entertainment journalist you can still
review movies cover movies and attend
press screenings initially I was like I
feel like we're not supposed to I don't
I I don't know like I was on the fence
about Oppenheimer for example but from
the updates and from talking with other
people who are actually sag seems like
that's actually okay because even in a
strike situation your attendance at a
press screening doesn't equate to
promoting The Struck company or its
product the whole point is to be there
as an impartial Observer delivering
information analysis or critique the
usual to the public and it's crucial to
maintain this distance and objectivity I
think even if there's not a strike
that's crucial to avoid any appearance
of endorsement or promotion as a strike
what it mostly targets is promotional
work typically covered under sag after
so from what I can see and this is like
you know uh more than just like
conversations it's been it has been a
lot of research from what I can see we
can proceed as normal if we just you
know we can't do any promotional things
we can't be like hey we want to use your
footage uh that we saw you do of
something and use it in our
advertisement can't say any agree to any
of that you can't do anything like hey
we want to send you this Spider-Man
habit at the end of the day that's going
to get approved from Disney that can't
do that so you know there's a whole
bunch of things that basically boil down
to just don't do promotional work for
them and obviously don't do any gigs or
auditions or anything that relate to
participating in one of the truck
companies movies or whatever so of
course we are maintaining an awareness
and we do care to be supportive because
frankly the fact of how the amptp is
treating our writers and actors is a
total uh deep dive a lot into
it on that podcast I did with Paul it's
not what this video is about but yeah if
you want to hear more about my opinions
on that please go ahead and check that
out and the day I firmly believe that
what they're fighting for is exactly
what they should be fighting for so if
we do anything that truly steps out of
bounds we'll do our best to correct it
anyway hope this information helps you
just let me know if it does uh leave
their thoughts Down Below on how you've
been feeling about the stack strike and
all that learn that I'll talk with you
guys soon thank you so much for being
here
[Music]